Hey it's me Destin and welcome back to Smarter Every Day
So I was challenged by Grant Thompson to do the Ice Bucket Challenge
and I want to do a video that's: smart, and teaches you something
, that's fun to watch
and something that actually ends up giving a lot of money to the ALS Research Cause.
We've got this dry ice, 'cause that's what Grant did
We're gonna put dry ice here in the, uh...
In the bucket.
We've got a phantom running about 1000 frames per second
Is this a good idea‽ -laughs-
(No)
It's not a good idea...
(bubbles)
Ha, are you ready ?
Do you wanna trigger it?
Okay, so here we go
ALS does affect your ability to react...
I don't really want to do this now...
Okay, so here we go
(sploosh)
(children laughing)
Yea it's funny, daddy's wet. Isn't it!
Okay my part is now done, now time for a little pseudoscience
Just for fun
What we're gonna do is test the reaction times for 4 different animals
As you know ALS affects the ability of nerves to fire muscles.
So we're gonna remove the ice so there's no danger to the animals at all,
and just put, just a little bit of water in there
so we can just startle them
Maybe splash beside them?
and see which ones react the fastest
This should be pretty fun!
Okay, take it and put some water in there
Yea, go put water in it!
First animal up:
My two-year-old son!
(laughs)
Are you ready to get wet?
Here you go!
Come here Buckshot!
Isn't that food good‽
(laughs)
She doesn't care!
Okay, now we're gonna test an old cat
Very good, Old Cat!
Man, look at all that food!
Lot of food, don't you like food, Speckles
(cluck cluck cluck cluck)
Okay, lets compare
Okay, in the end I hope you realised that:
This was an educational video
and you leaned something about amyotrophic lateral sclerosis
or ALS, Lou Gehrig's Disease
I hope it was entertaining,
I had fun, I hope you did too
And number three
I hope you recognize that we're gonna convert whisker shaving to scientific reasearch
to help people
(plop)
Okay, this time we're gonna let it get really really cold
with the dry ice before we drop it
so,
While we are doing that let me explain to you
how I'm actually gonna donate to ALS reasearch
I was listening to my favourite pod cast: Hello Internet
when my friend, Brady, did an ad for this
which is Harry's Razors
It's a really cool razor subscription service
that I use after I listened to him on Hello Internet talk about it
I really like it and I've taken it all over the world with me
So, if you're interested in supporting Smarter Every Day go to...
Harry's.com and you get subscription razors, like this
just do that, that one falls off you get another one
you're good to go, it's really awesome, I really like it
use that promo code SMARTER, they'll give you $5 off
I'm gonna use this money to help you donate to ALS
this should be cold now, let's do it
here we go!
(splash)
all right, there you go
if you're interested... uhh, go to harry's.com and use the promo code SMARTER
if I recommend it to you, and you do it
we can convert whisker shaving into scientific reasearch
which is pretty cool
by all means, don't let it stop you from donating straight up to ALS research
however, I like the product
and, if that gets more money into ALS reasearch
I'm all about it
so if you're interested go to harry's.com
use the promo code smarter
and you'll get a discount and I'll get cred for doing it
and maybe in the future they'll sponsor me and I can use it for other stuff
But for now...
harry's.com, the promo code SMARTER
I'm Destin and you're getting smarter every day
Have a good one!